Mm,
all systems of oppression are highly
adaptive and they can adapt to
challenges and incorporate them.
They can allow for exceptions,
and I think the most effective
adaptation of the system of racism to
the challenges of the civil rights
movement was to reduce a racist to a
very simple formula.
A racist is an individual,
always an individual,
not a system who consciously does not
like people based on race must be
conscious and who intentionally seeks to
be mean to them.
Individual conscious intent.
And if that is my definition of a
racist,
then your suggestion that anything I've
said or done is racist or has a racist
impact.
I'm going to hear that as you just said,
I was a bad person.
You just put me over there in that
category.
And most of my bias anyway is
unconscious.
So I,
I'm not intending,
I'm not aware.
Uh,
so now I'm going to need to defend my
moral character.
And,
and I will,
and we've all seen it.
It seems to be virtually impossible
based on that definition for the average
white person to look deeply at their
socialization,
to look at the inevitability of
internalizing racist biases,
developing racist patterns,
and having investments in the system of
racism,
which is pretty comfortable for us and
serves us really well.
I think that definition of a racist that
either or what I call the good bad
binary is the root of virtually all
white defensiveness on this topic
because it makes it virtually impossible
to talk to the average white person
about the inevitable absorption of a
racist worldview that we get by being
literally swimming in racist water.
So let me connect that to myself as a
result of being raised as a white person
in this society.
I have a racist worldview.
I have a deep racist biases.
I have developed a racist patterns and I
have investments in the system of racism
because it's served me really well.
It's comfortable.
It's helped me overcome the barriers
that I do face and I also have an
investment and not seeing any of that
for what it would suggest to me about my
identity and what it would require of
me.
Right.
I didn't choose any of that.
I don't feel guilty about it.
It isn't inevitable result of being
raised in this society in which racism
is the bedrock.
The question of guilt comes in in what
am I doing about that?
While we who are white tend to be
fragile in that it doesn't take much to
upset us around race.
The impact of our response is not
fragile at all.
It's a kind of weaponized defensiveness,
weaponized hurt feelings,
right,
and it functions really,
really effectively to repel the
challenge.
There was a white person,
I moved through the world,
racially comfortable,
virtually 24 slash seven.
It is exceptional for me to be outside
of my racial comfort zone and most of my
life I've been warned not to go outside
my racial comfort zone and so on the
rare occasion when I am uncomfortable
racially,
it's.
It's a kind of throwing off of my racial
equilibrium and I need to get back into
that and so I will do whatever it takes
to repel the challenge and get back into
it and in that way I think white
fragility functions as a kind of white
racial bullying.
To be frank,
we make it so miserable for people of
color to talk to us about are inevitable
and often unaware of racist patterns
that we cannot help develop from being
socialized into a culture in which
racism is the bedrock and the
foundation.
We make it so miserable for them to talk
to us about it that most of the time
they don't just and we just have to
understand that most people of color
that are working or living in primarily
white environments take home way more
daily slights and hurts and insults than
they bother talking to us about
because their experiences,
they're going to risk more punishment.
They're going to lose the relationship.
They're going to have their experience
minimized,
explained away.
They're going to cause the person to
feel attacked or hurt.
And in that way,
white fragility functions as a kind of
everyday white racial control.
None of that has to be intentional or
conscious,
but that is how it functions and it's
actually incredibly liberating and
transformative to start from the premise
that,
of course I've internalized all of this
and then I can stop defending,
deflecting,
denying,
hoping you won't notice,
minimizing,
explaining,
and I can just let go of that and get to
work.
And there's a question that's never
failed me in my efforts to unpack.
How do we pull this off?
How do so many of us who are white
individually feel so free of racism and
yet we live in a society that is so
profoundly separate and unequal by race.
And the question that's never failed me
is not,
is this true or is this false?
Is this writer,
is this wrong?
But how does it function?
How do these narratives that I tell,
how do they function when I tell you,
well,
I'm just an individual.
Why can't we all just be individuals?
When I tell you I was taught to treat
everyone the same.
When I tell you what it's focusing on
race that divides us.
When I tell you I have lots of friends
of color,
those narratives have not changed our
outcome and they functioned to take race
off the table and to exempt the person
from any further engagement,
and in doing that,
they functioned to protect the current
racial hierarchy in the white position
within it.
It doesn't have to be what I'm intending
to do,
but it is the impact of those
narratives.